[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about what we - a look at
Steve sick-ass jacket no you can't be
it's [ __ ] sick oh my god is that a
new jacket
listen he has a better jack I like that
jacket I cede the keys he has a better
jackets where's Casey my in-laws got it
for me so I good but I guess the in-laws
oh my dad got a FRU since you're salty
you get like does it get really short
because I have that yeah oh yeah yeah
tall people it's really fun dude some of
these chicks my friend Jess she's like
411 and her jacket so like that on her
dude that's cute that's weird right
that's like the formative I don't know I
don't know guys before you showed me
that I was like you guys are pretty
normal and then you guys show me that
and I don't mean to you yeah this is
nothing like is matter like you know I
had a roll mine up I like rolling up the
shirts I like that what suits rolling it
up cuz it's not like the clothes as in
your dress shirt pops out a little bit
more and you look like a poker player
yeah like what suits I was just talking
to Casey about this over the weekend it
a lot of the Asian kids I went to high
school with had an incredible style yeah
like they and they would they would roll
all of their shirts up to the sleeves
and [ __ ] [ __ ] look like a military
pressed shirt like they work at Apple or
something yeah and then I meet you guys
I'm like okay yeah there's uh not
everyone just incredibly done yeah
because you were dealing with Asians in
a beach town oh is that what it is
sorry Asians in a hood town Oh San Diego
yeah I wish you guys would have met them
when they were like in their gangster
why it was [ __ ] [ __ ] I've seen pics
it was horrible I'm glad I'm not in them
yeah wifebeaters were the uniform of my
daily uniform ah yeah you're bald
oh yeah that's true that's still
old-school pretty nuts that way like you
look scary with you knowing you but I
was like a hunch
20 pounds - yeah bald it's kinda scary
I think I saw a picture of that really
yeah did you post one maybe was every
picture were you like hey let me do it
again I'm gonna [ __ ] you up you have
like really long shorts and like I to do
retakes I was two guys with a disposable
cameras it can't really do retakes it
wastes a number right like scroll it and
it's like oh I only have 15 left and you
have to wait for the flash yeah if we
want it to be like dressy what we did is
we call a Dickies shirt
oh yeah that's more presentable we
embroider just kidding films with Old
English we started the company yeah
you're actually looking closer to that
Joe since you shaved yeah oh really and
I'm going more like that's crazy go back
in time yeah because you do look like
just more like fresh face cleaner yeah
well when I lost weight I was like
alright it's time to do it just shave it
off mm-hmm or did it in Europe - what
what made you want to shave it off when
he started losing weight
he just looks better was it a fat guy
cover up the beard yeah yeah it was yeah
yeah cuz it breaks up the cheeks in I
don't know just contours your face
Dannan you get used to doing something
[ __ ] broth yes you know yeah guys have a
full beard their jawline looks like 300
like he knows me years where the guys
have like a big-ass bushy beard and then
so they show the beard and then once he
shaves it he has like no chin cuz it's
like they made the beard into like a
good trench a jawline yeah that's why
beards look good on a lot of guys cuz it
makes a false jawline mmm that makes
sense that makes sense some guys do it
in some guys have a jaw then I'm like
damn dude you should cover that with
Barry so sharp like that's - sure yeah
there's jaws that are - some wounds is
too sharp no who's the cat who uh
the rich cat who has mom supermodel all
over hospitals Aryan
beer damn I know he looks good with the
beard oh really have you seen him
without a beard looks like a method I
don't like it like his face is because
its face it goes like this and then he
sucked in all weird like Daniel
day-lewis losing 100 pounds and then so
the the beard kind of like squares it
out and makes it look looks like
masculine got it you ever had a guy go
down on you with a beard
no but I kind of gave her a beard no no
does it feel weird I've never had it I
don't think I would like it I think if
you give what if they use it as a
technique yeah I think parking or beard
if you in 1000 days
he tried type of skin all right got
thousand a day not a few you never you
weren't his friend when he grew it out
he went out for like months pumping oh
yeah it looked like just here yeah like
just here you see her face so close that
I don't think you can grow hair from it
he's like I haven't shaved in 10 days I
do have to shave like every two or three
days no but it's still not like rich you
know caught it do you have to shave
daily hmm it's like every other day I
had him shave the chinstrap recently
yeah well I have I get ingrown hairs so
I had to I had to wait for them to like
because if he shaves them when he has
ingrown hairs it gets worse it's like
blisters it's like another month of
aggravation so I have to have to be very
careful about when the hot towel
treatment yeah yeah I do oh yeah
actually makes a sauna and help softens
up your hair follicles yeah that's what
I'm always wasting in the water you know
really sad the water really hot and I
put the the razor in there to make it
nice and hot and then it cuts way
smoother and he's keeping it running the
whole time as he's doing that you do
that well we're in a drought too Wow yes
of course
like how you gotta do something for
saying that you didn't just say no you
get one thing for a way out I can find
one day you even but you like open the
door to that yourself it was locked and
no one was trying to go to do that
conversation and they hear like you know
what I'm gonna open this too wide and I
was gonna get myself there I know where
that door went yeah I didn't know I
don't like facial hair it itches too
much I actually hate it I agree I also
don't like you don't like facial
throwing now on me oh when it's growing
in it you gonna want me I don't like
that because it's very scratchy oh yeah
does it be smooth yeah I like it smooth
when it's in a nice that I'm born our
new yeah okay with the pubes - you want
a medal throwing back a little
recognition yeah yeah start a [ __ ]
cookie over the bare minimum I don't
like cookies I mention okay something
savory but yeah they wouldn't people
screwing
yes [ __ ] hurts yeah like it's like
it's not what are you saying about pubes
when they curl I better talk about beers
what do you say my beards hmm litora
talk about behaviors still you still
we've done
what about pubes don't know like what
period of your genitals yeah exactly
yes so like when it's growing out that
should hurt yeah especially if there's
like hair at the base of like the penis
yeah that [ __ ] I thought you're talking
about vagina it's like you're sanding it
down hey so the peanut I get it out okay
so this part was a dick you mean the
hair like right right here and then it's
growing back
yeah about her yeah that's crazy cuz I'd
like that you like what do you like
about it
I like that told me pretty as [ __ ]
maybe because he's not very hairy so
it's not like a lot like it's not as
like peach fuzz you're like
[Laughter]
I wish you could grow this here over
here I don't give a [ __ ] clearly don't
care there's so many solutions for that
yeah they're [ __ ] but it's a it's a
lot of involvement the thing that where
they glue they put glue down and then
they like it's called feathering have
you heard of that really like they like
blow dry bits and pieces of hair into
your hair with the adhesive on it and it
looks like your hair I want the one
where they take the strip from the back
the transplant so what do they do
that's a Brandi Lee well he doesn't do
the brand deal so if he does the brand
deal maybe he could pay for it himself
it's very involved it's very involved
what do you mean by involve you like
they do when they do it to your head
like your face like [ __ ] swells up
for like a week and [ __ ] it's like a lot
you take a week off or somewhere are you
a [ __ ] mom how does it work though
clearly Marvel a lot yeah it's like it's
a surgery so they scalp you yeah what's
the difference between that and hair
plugs
a hair plugs they like insert the I
don't think they do that anymore so you
you you don't have a patch of hair like
back here it's gone funny though well
what if it doesn't
don't be so funny you have a rectangle
gone here
would you have more hair did you guys
see the story of the chick that got skin
grafting is that what it's called she
she had an I think a dog did her face
and then she had to get I hope we're not
talking about this but she had to get
they had to take remove skin from her
her groin area her vagina
yeah and they put it on her face hope
it's the same color I don't know if this
is a fake news but then she started
growing pubic oh yeah I was gonna ask
holy [ __ ] it looks way too smell funny
to like hurt it smell good let this all
be a wrong door sir I think it's not
really good from but she just had this
thing all really good now he [ __ ] up I
heard that what I didn't even say
anything oh no no I'm just letting you
know that he [ __ ] up nobody can hear
me I'm being like I'm just saying he
came up with that I know why are you
trying to put yourself in the same but
no one is accusing you he wants to open
doors he wants to watch this thing apart
so precor's over here doors opening
that's right we're a Home Depot trying
doors Oh Joe's gone girl you've not even
listening to us it's probably like when
I close the door you get about mud I
have the same face within my oh you know
what's happening you a little Joe face
and they're going because I'm like you
haven't for all we know Joe sing about
tornadoes right now he's not here he's
like worth it tornadoes on the other way
whatever talking about boring [ __ ] when
I put those Dickie shirt that I was
wearing
that's a good question there are those I
threw that [ __ ] away as soon as the Rudy
waiting branded they're not in there
yeah they're in there I'm did you guys
have wallets with chains and [ __ ] no oh
yeah I was amazed that was cool back
then you had like that I was not your
clip yeah well not high school maybe
like junior high elementary if you were
Dickies you had spiked hair and you had
a wallet chain and she goes oh so wet
for you wait you had a wallet chain no
no no as a boy thing oh I don't know
it's for guys on this your pictures I
did yeah I did where boy pants like boy
Dickies and spike belts but no wallet
chain because I didn't have a wallet
I had Ida purse I was a lady you have a
channel
Oh was it a dick you first it was like
no but I wanted
like a leopard purse I just like like I
was trying to sell furniture at Ashley's
furniture and I was a Salesman that's
all what changed
yeah what does that mean oh no I had the
jacket change button ups and [ __ ]
jeans good tasty good you know really my
dad got it for him he's my dad so cute -
he was like it texted me like two months
before Christmas like you think stupid
like this and I was like yeah and he's
like they have different colors and he
gave me who's your dad dress well yeah
he dresses really well dude I was so
sick on Christmas that people are
handing me presents and [ __ ] and I was
basically [ __ ] shivering and
incontinent oh yeah and everyone's hand
any presents and then Nicky at one point
Nicky covers me in presents and she's
like honey you gonna open these and I'm
like I can barely open them for you like
I was like whatever does okay this looks
so good on you this is from Mike this is
from your in-laws you still went to a
Christmas party while you did that sir
oh yeah I mean a party it was like
Christmas morning we all go to my aunt's
house and open presents like with all
the cousins oh it's like a family yeah
it was stuck dude because the night
before it wasn't I wasn't that bad and
then the next day it was nuts
everyone got sick guys flock during the
break huh yeah people still are getting
sick oh yeah still back around people
that were sick got better or getting
real sick again I know I was sick the
whole time - I didn't know I was
supposed to in Europe yeah I woke up
with a fever one day and it just went
away one day fever yeah and then it went
away and then I got sick again with the
fever I have you for days I had a fever
for like a week because if I tell me saw
a doctor for you you didn't have a fever
and I had the fever first white a fever
but it wasn't bad sure you had been 99
that's how that's a fever barely a fever
that's barely a few that gets you out of
school in my house
that's like 0.2 degrees ahead of what it
normally is dude I used to try to heat
my head up before my mom would feel it
cuz she was did that mom yeah yeah
outdoor the play gets a boy three extra
covers no I pick up a fever and then I
do all this friction [ __ ] where I put on
my head and [ __ ] I would just get into
the blanket like you know you can't
breathe because everything's like
trapped in there and it just becomes
like your own little sauna I used to do
that and then I would get really sweaty
and so that's crazy you got say cuz you
never get sick I never told my mom one
time I'm sick
I always said oh I'm sick you know I'm
saying yeah you have to like you to give
them what a good one is what you don't
or you the good one is you don't tell
them you're sick cousin they pick your
spoon feed it you're like I'm not
feeling good that's what I'm in a hot
here and the kind of one yeah oh I think
they're sick I'm like you said it yeah
oh that's good
I'd always be like a cure this way and
they're like no but I can't miss school
yeah yeah yeah you gotta pretend like
you want it but like that's real for you
though like you really didn't want to
miss it yeah for the most part cuz you
wanted to keep good grades
yeah like some days and I didn't know
about then it was like a mental health
day where I just felt really sad and I
just didn't want to go to school but I
didn't want to miss school either so
wasn't a lie is just that I just felt
too sad to go to school you know I used
to fake sick all that [ __ ] and then once
I got into girls I'd never faked that
[ __ ] again we see in the math school do
you want to see him at dude I would've
showed up I could have my leg blown off
and I'm like I'm like on the [ __ ]
crutches to see chicks dude you are a
true
I think Elementary is when I just wanted
to stay home all the time and I faked
sick to the point where I got pneumonia
oh [ __ ] I went to the hospital I got
steve-o to yourself ya know see blood
it's called an OC blood used to you you
faked it until you got sick so much to
the point where yeah I actually got sick
hardcore and I was at the hospital
see you like funky like I don't get it
he doesn't have anything he's just stuck
in the scene that's crazy yeah I think
six so much that my parents actually
held me back for a year really gonna put
me in school and so I was always a year
older they held you back what was your
birthday
that is what huh please don't please
don't do this to me what month lizard
Richard birthday August
oh is that consider early he's more than
a year older than me but we graduated
the same year yeah but I wasn't held
back yeah you were you just said you
were held back no but I wasn't held back
you know I'm saying when you get held
back it's cause like you suck at math
whatever yeah yeah he was held back I
wasn't held back I chose to be back
no you choose to be back so like I came
back so you know I'm into that military
school and I thought motors we have all
these traditions so you if you go in you
have to start a year later like there's
no way you can go in like you already
finish this often we have to do two
sophomore over cuz you have to do all
the motion to do traditions I didn't
oddly get kicked out of that school
oh [ __ ] you no I'll just I'll do my
junior junior over when I went back to
my old school I had enough credits to
graduate as a senior but then all my
friends that I made now were juniors saw
just like a long boys like you guys all
bad cuz you were dumb you just said that
I got held back because I was dope damn
I remember I kind of sort out a little
bit did too but not really just say it
cuz everyone's gonna make you say it
anyway you even understand what happened
to you they do story for it I do
actually
okay so for sixth grade I ended up
moving cities and in the new city I went
to there was no more because it was in
the middle of year so there were no more
mm-hmm like space there was no space for
me in the new middle middle school so
because of that my mom ended up having
to put me in a Catholic school
at this Catholic school they didn't have
any more room in the 6th grade so they
put me in the 5th grade
oh they had no more space that's [ __ ]
up yeah why would even accept you
let's just randomly pick someone yes sup
can't just bring a beach chair or
something no extra person no the same
case in the public school - that's why
she ended up having to take me to the
private school so I did
are you sure just tell you they randomly
selected you they do your mom say like
this yeah they ran out of room so this
is sake and go anything for Texas and
they get more deserts event at the South
Gate knows that only people that have
gone to elementary school in South Gate
are allowed to go into middle school
it's a self gate because there's that
many people oh there's just not any room
so then that's when my mom ended up
taking me to the Catholic school but
yeah and then I was asking I'm like once
I got in I was like why can't it be in
the 6th grade and then those teachers
are like yeah there's no more space so
I'm like okay school have space there
yeah Wow go to sake girl I don't want to
don't base you were there's no space so
it was a Catholic schoolgirl for like a
couple months and then my mom ended up
taking me back to Downey and then I had
to take the bus from South Gate to
Downey oh that was insane did you go
back into the sixth grade no I ended up
going to seventh grade what the high
finished sixth - they sped you up I
finished sixth grade as a Catholic
school as a fifth grader and then I
ended up quitting so you got held back
and you skip yeah sixth grade was the
best year of my life and you miss any
miss my god I was stupid socially like
so super super immature and they wanted
to skip me because like academically I
was more advanced so I learned how to
read which wasn't born in the mine ya
know so dumb
try to fit in so gel I couldn't fit in
social matter what your shirt your mouth
it's gonna happen to okay win the
lottery music for Ron doors to
[Music]